puis on vous accueille à cette émission
en direct du canada autour de la table
on a deux collègues de travail
marie-jo un bonjour bonjour stéphane et
samir ben jafar qui cette semaine ne
travaillent avec nous en plus de
travailler dans une section autres dans
la ccravh donc je travaille avec vous
cette semaine
merci de m'avoir invité aujourd'hui et
cette femme comme c'est toujours un
plaisir d'être présent ici
en fait ça bien s'est invitée à
l'émission et sa fête le 200e droit de
trois semaines à peu près oui parce
qu'il l'a dit il faudrait que tu évites
telle personne est l'émission tu vois
c'est très intéressant je dis ouais
d'accord mais ce qu'il ne sait pas c'est
que on a un peu trafiqué les choses il
ya plus qu'un éviter aujourd'hui les
nations hockey et le sujet que de
l'émission que vous pensez qu'ils
étaient le sujet des missions c'est pas
ça ce n'est pas parfait
alors je vous présente la vidéo 5 images
au saas et de stéphane parent crèche
cinq images pour que vous essayez de me
dire c'est quoi le sujet aujourd'hui et
tous ceux qui regardent en ce moment
peuvent jouer le même jeu
tout le monde part avec la même base
d'égalité c'est à dire l'inconnaissance
qualité des chances alors regarde ça ça
ça en vienne ou du temps ça du côté de
la technique aujourd'hui ses envies mais
c'est vrai qu'on est une tempête de
neige cette semaine donc les choses
bougent un peu plus lentement alors ça
ça parle de véhicules donc mode de
transport musulmans certainement des
vieux véhicules
probablement que ça soyons sera question
ça c'est un producteur d'électricité de
ce que vous pensez ça s'appelle pas un
alternateur vous vous y connaissez vous
tenez m'emparer t il il aimait ces
choses là
et qu'est ce que c'est ça ça c'est une
turbine dans le secteur électrique sur
la piste alors c'est quoi le sujet
aujourd'hui d'écouter les transports
électriques
oui on peut rien vous cacher vous allez
voir c'est une émission pour ceux qui
veulent dire du mal des véhicules
électriques
ah oui parce que tu as eu le droit tout
n'est pas parfait dans la vie ouais mais
il ya eu beaucoup de bonnes publicité
faite pour l'auto électrique approche
j'en ai acheté une
je me suis laissé avoir donc je dévoile
tout j'ai un prix jugé trop électrique
mais j'entends des choses
des fois ok j'ai pas répondre ce mois
mais je sais pas quoi répondre
comment le vivez toucher les batteries
d'auto électrique ça pollue énormément
oui le cycle de vie d'une auto
électrique aussi à la fin s'est produit
en moi j'ai été choqué quand j'ai lu cet
article ce radio canada il ya quelques
mois mais ça m'a en tout cas ça c'était
vraiment choqué ça marche ça m'a poussé
à aller chercher encore plus de
profondeur pour voir est ce que c'est
vrai bon s'essaya les pour et les contre
je pense que notre invité peut-être il
n'y a plus servi un discours aussi
beaucoup les débats beaucoup autour la
façon où ce qu'on va chercher et ce
qu'on fait pour pouvoir produire les
métaux qu'on va utiliser pour les
batteries électriques et métaux précieux
oui ben aussi comment est-ce que
l'électricité compense avec laquelle en
charge la voiture à ce qu'elle est pour
lui en parler c'est pas tout le temps
faire le tour de la planète comme vous
le désirez mais on va faire un bout de
piste ensemble rassurez-vous tout
commence par cette première boule à mort
des huit premiers jeux de la grosse
boule aujourd'hui 20 vols à perdre c'est
la tradition sens voulu par édition à
perdre
ok là aussi la question la fiche pour
tout le monde pour le plaisir de tous et
chacun en subventions combien vont
coûter
je vous donne une commune préambule
d'abord l'objectif du québec mais c'est
d'avoir cent mille véhicules électriques
sur les routes et on offre 8000 $ aux
contribuables d'accord qui veut acheter
une auto électrique neuf alors la
question suivante en subventions
convient à mon goût vont coûter au
contraire canadien la présence de ces
cent mille véhicules électriques
est ce que c'est au total 8 millions $
en subventions 80 millions de dollars
dont subventions 800 millions de dollars
en subventions ou encore ma préférée
aucune de ces réponses pour moi c'est
non pas pour moi aucune sans réponse
pourquoi
et moi aussi et parce que vous avez
compris à cent mille contribuables
canadiens
les kaya le 8000 $ au québec mais à 5000
au canada mc alger
c'est ça on affiche la bonne réponse ça
fait au total de 5000 $ de subventions
par véhicule potentiellement ça et puis
ça fait combien ça en millions de
dollars
non ça les mecs ça fait 1 million 300
mille chance non 13 minutes perdu
transmis des noms d'ailleurs vous avez
il ya des provinces qui ont décidé
qu'ils ont reculé sur la subvention et
c'est le cas de nos tares oui l'ontario
mais c'est aller en cours mais je ne
sais pas s'il a entre concert et encourt
quatorze mille dinars de subventions en
ontario ceux qui voulaient acheter un
véhicule électrique jusqu'à haut disons
les premiers mois de l'an dernier
alors écoutez cette question de la
subvention des véhicules aux véhicules
électriques
il ya des gens qui disent mais écoutez
on offre ça aux gens en général qui ont
un petit peu plus d'argent que la
moyenne alors tous les contribuables
même les plus pauvres contribuer à cet
enrichissement des plus est ce qu'on
devrait faire ça ou est-ce qu'on
n'aurait pas adopter d'autres stratégies
pour parler des aspects négatifs dont on
discute souvent dans les médias
concernant l'automobile autos
électriques pour l'automobile
16 05 le dernier pardonnez moi alors on
a un invité premier invité aujourd'hui
et on va aller le chercher
pas loin d'ici en fait je pense qu'il
est à montréal avec de l'association des
véhicules électriques du québec et
participe pas beaucoup d'entre vous
allez le voir souvent la télévision
simon pierre rioux monsieur rioux bons
jours plus tard dans quelques minutes on
va vous voir même au volant d'un
véhicule électrique en train de tester
pour radio-canada un modèle en
particulier je pense que c'était
peut-être à l'occasion d'un salon de
l'auto électrique à montréal y en a eu
quelques-uns d'abord répondant à cette
première question
soyons soyons vilain si vous voulez mais
la visée pourquoi est-ce qu'on
subventionne des des consommateurs qui
ont les moyens de s'acheter un véhicule
électrique
en fait je réponde à la question parce
que les réponses et des c'est vraiment
aucune de ces réponses parce que c'est
le marché du carbone qui va pouvoir
offrir c'est que ces contributions là
donc ce n'est pas le contribuable
canadien qui paye peau c'est le marché
du karaoke
ou des grands pollueurs et lui il va y
avoir des subventions
si on arrête le marché du carbone une
yole subventions puis sans lui faudrait
que ce soit les contribuables qui paient
ce oui il peut y avoir deux donc j'adore
j'adore votre choix drake nationale ben
rhodes jacent à cette question-là 1
milliard 300 millions $ en voici ce que
disent les gens qui sont les apôtres du
transport en commun à montréal qui
voudraient des prolongements de métro
ici et lingots à gauche ni à droite et
du nord au sud
alors pourrait prolonger d'au moins 1
qu'il avait avec le métro de montréal
avec un milliard trois cents millions
pourquoi est-ce qu'on investit repas
plutôt dans le transport en commun
plutôt que d'encourager l'utilisation de
véhicules électriques
il faut réparer les routes ils vont
continuer à encourager l'utilisation
d'automobiles écouter ces sapins que on
investit déjà énormément des transports
en commun pourquoi on irait donner de
l'argent des gens qui sont là sauf états
unis en fait oui peut-être qu'elle est
en ce moment c'est que pour débuter un
changement au doigt et fluence déjà d un
peu plus d'argent qu'ils sont capables
de se permettent d'acheter le véhicule
électrique ou à personne
les gens m'ont gardé véhicule un caprin
leurs ventes du marché de l'occasion qui
on la vend moins cher
puis le véhicule de véhicules
électriques
on peut s'attendre à une durée de vie de
1 million de kilomètres avant des
problèmes donc le vie qu'il va durer
beaucoup plus longtemps qu'en pensent
les véhicules est en dessous après deux
cent mille kilomètres on commence à
poser question est ce que c'est un de le
vendre parce que lors des problèmes
mécaniques
la batterie est bonne pour un qu'ils
aient le moteur est bon pour abus
millions km donc c'est des véhicules qui
sont faites pour durer
quand on arrive après kaisin est le
changement de la batterie ne se fait pas
automatiquement la batterie encore bondi
d'environ 70 % de sa capacité initiale
donc celui que tu voiture est très
longtemps pour les capable
les gaz est fait un nom côté
environnemental qui est important c'est
pas fui ses restes d'un véhicule qui
plus dispendieux initialement parce que
c'était une très petite production au
produit environ 1% des manufactures il
60000 vit que pour un véhicule pour la
planète au complet donc son produit 5000
véhicules versus 1 million de micra par
exemple sa micra du coup depuis qu'ils
voient tous vous avez que son après du
par millions là ça nous ça va être
intéressant c'est lorsqu'on va commencer
à produire ces véhicules la centaine de
pays par millions d'exemplaires estimant
on sera plus obligé de subventions aux
sur nuke on compte oui excusez moi nous
avons un temple pour l'utilisation des
véhicules électriques
l'acheteur bénéficie de subventions ils
utilisent la route tout ça mais il n'y a
aucune contribution par exemple comme si
moi j'ai un véhicule à essence je dois
payer des taxes et pour l'utilisation de
la route tout ça pourquoi le celui qui
tue le véhicule électrique
il est exclu de ça il en plus de ça il
reçoit des subventions en plus il est
classé dans dans la catégorie qui a de
l'argent qui peut s'acheter des choses
que le commun des contribuables ne peut
pas généralement m'a écouté les taxons
carré pays sur les utilisations
lectrices paix ont été utilisés sur le
réseau de rechange public
c'est donc ils s'appellent taxes qui
sont utilisés l'argent est réinvesti de
toute façon parce que oui à
l'utilisation de véhicules pour les
beaucoup moins cher donc par exemple si
je fais vraiment km par année
je vais payer 2500 $ en essence où je
vais 300 da racing
mais cet argent leur que je vais
économiser je le veux dire acheter
d'autres trucs à faire des voyages etc
l'argent revient de toute façon dans la
société d'une façon différente mais il
dit il revient de toute façon ce qui
brille en ce moment c'est un avantage
le bel avantage de marrons à payer de
taxes
raison mais certains états ou aux états
unis par exemple qui ont décidé d'avoir
une contribution des propriétaires de
véhicules électriques
ils ont chiffré à al sadd armes pour
nous assurer qu'on remonte un coupable
québec c'est certain que lorsqu'il va y
avoir une présence plus importante de
véhicules électriques sont nombreux
szavay d'important pour nous de regarder
la taxe kilométrique pour justement
aider à soutenir à détenir les autres
structures
merci est ce que vous entendez beaucoup
parler des problèmes liés à la
production de ces piles électriques pour
les voitures
parce que on entendait parler que au
lieu de venir peut-être chercher de ces
métaux précieux au québec qui coûte si
cher à exploiter on va par exemple en
amérique du sud dans quoi de la bolivie
dans quoi de certains pays chercher du
matériel qui est plus facile alors on
détruit des chartes celle d'un mec parce
que ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
est ce qu'un danger moment donné de
avoir un mauvais impact sur
l'environnement en même temps qu'on
développe cette cette filière qui se
pose est plus propre
c'est important qu'on puisse bien
développe les choses on parle ici de
cobalt c'est plus difficile
on essaie de diminuer l'utilisation du
cobalt dans les batteries lithium ion
nouvelle matière pour s'assurer qu'on
reproche justement l exploiter des mines
dans des pays en voie de développement
qui pourraient avoir un peu n'est plus
un parti au niveau environnemental mais
s'est adressée par à ce moment là mais
on diminue de beaucoup d'utilisation du
global dans des batteries puis dans la
suite nous on va voir que je pense que
vous avez d'autres experts au niveau des
bêtes pour vous en parler aux plus
gradés pas aimé ça change énormément on
veut changer la composition des
batteries
ce sera pas toujours une batterie sommes
donc oui présentement ses beats y sommes
c'est le cobalt manganèse
mais on va changer la composition tous
issus des bd matin qui sont plus
facilement accès sont plus
sincèrement je n'en sais pas plus moins
cher également
donc les gens changent présentement
c'est ce qu'on utilise des méthodes et
procédés industriels sont plus
écologiques
oui même si rio moi j'ai toujours ce
souci les gens qui ont des véhicules
électriques ils sont supposés avoir des
maisons pour pouvoir au moins les
charges et mais c'est pas tout le monde
qui est propriétaire et ceux qui
habitent dans deux dans des appartements
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent utiliser
des voitures électriques qui peuvent pas
les charger dans la rue j'imagine que
c'est pas pratique 12 vous dans votre
association est ce que vous avez pensé à
ce type de de clientèle à cette
catégorie de clientèle pour les voitures
électriques
absolument pour nous c'est important que
les poux le monde ait accès à des
véhicules les traits qu'on s'est battu
pour que les gens puissent aussi acheter
des véhicules usagés un rabais aux
véhicules électriques usagés au québec
selon certaines règles à suivre à mai on
sait que ses potes tout le monde sont
propriétaires d'une maison qui ont vous
restez à une borne de recharge
on peut recharger à sans vivres ont
besoin une borne de recharge ya de plus
en plus de bande se ruent dans les
grandes villes dont montréal et québec
les autres villes peuvent vraiment donc
ça peut être un peu plus compliqué à des
bandes de recharge rapide permettent de
recharger le véhicule en 20 à 30 minutes
ont compris tu sais ces bornes là pour
faire une recherche d'une fois par
semaine ou deux fois par semaine ou être
capable de taper de saintdo trajets
quotidiens sur scène des choses qui
valent mais par la suite on sapin avec
les logiques libérales comme avant à
magasiner beaucoup plus d'énergie à plus
de kilométrage justement conduit souvent
des bandes de rechange ultra rapide
vous savez le changement 5 à 10,9
beaucoup c'est ce qu'on aimerait capable
de faire parce que on regarde seulement
au québec mais sanguin ailleurs c'est
que ce sera toujours le cas
on proposera chargé faut que des
infrastructures de la charge les 30 plus
facile pour les ja complet monsieur
rioux on voulait continuer à tirer à
boulet rouge sur vous mais parce qu de
munitions dans ce cirque on avait
d'autres questions mais on va aller vers
un autre spécialiste de la question du
des véhicules automobiles et des
batteries notamment ses fameuses
batteries et sur lesquels on se pose
beaucoup de questions notamment
environnementales merci beaucoup d'avoir
mis la table aujourd'hui
et puis vous représentez bien le camp
des des positifs des portes quand on
parle de batterie merci beaucoup
alors s'est invitée avec lequel le
courant passait bien et à simon pierre
qui ont n'avez vous donc de
l'association des véhicules électriques
du québec 2e tour la grosse boule
oui mais je retiendrai apple avait déjà
perdu 20 points parce que vous répondiez
pas la bonne réponse est non
[Musique]
j'ai tardé vous truquez mais bien passée
voire franchement la zac des étudiants
de vendre si vous écoutez bien bon
écoute et voici la question va l'affiché
vous avez pas besoin d'écouter le besoin
de lire refusez vous voilà quelle est la
taxe minimale en norvège sur un véhicule
possédant un moteur à combustion ici on
offre des subventions à l'achat d'accord
en norvège on dit pas question
d'impliquer l'argent des contribuables
ou des fonds de du carbone là dedans on
va demander aux gens de payer si
j'achète encore un de ces vieux
véhicules avec moteur à combustion
polluantes qui sent mauvais alors est-ce
que c'est 5000 dollars en taxe minimale
sur un véhicule vieux genre qu'on impose
la classe s ami e s que cb dix mille
dollars
est ce que c'est c'est 15 mille dollars
mon dieu ou est ce que c'est des 20000
dollars pays qui veut avoir tous les
véhicules électriques d'ici quelques
années et c'est un pays qui produit du
pétrole oscillaient c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident on offre aux quais
mille dollars en subventions
automobilistes québécois alors est-ce
qu'on va taxer 15000 dollars en norvège
est ce que ça va être si la bonne
réponse
est-ce que ça va être bon y a pas aucune
de ces réformes n'a pas écouté mon jeu
vers loin parce que ça va plus dans un
pays où il ya la prison française
quelque part ce qu'il est vendeur de
mauvaise réponse je donnerai pas vendeur
de véhicules usagés et everell avec
samir ou tentez votre chance
on va aller sur nohain parce que 5000 $
de taxes pour juste pour alors on y va
on va aller sur un peu comme le jeu du
pendu allait tomber tous les deux c'est
qu'à metz du fric à temps là ils ont
commis deux véhicules électriques
maintenant bah écoutez c'est la moitié
des véhicules à ce moment qu'ils sont
des véhicules électriques ont souvent dû
mais que ça peut faire la leçon du côté
de la norvège
on continue à produire du pétrole à être
très a bénéficié de ça et en même temps
pénalise les gens chez nous on veut bien
paraître à la maison met en avant notre
pétrole ailleurs chose est certaine
c'est bien conduire en norvège coûte
plus cher qu'ici c'est la boxe et la
moyenne là alors écoutez on a quelqu'un
que qui est un invité spécial de samir
ben jaafer cette semaine et vous à nu le
présentez vous l'avez rencontrée à
personne vous aidez les à son
laboratoire
oui oui s'agit maintenant d'une vedette
des médias puisqu'on le connaît il a
passé à quelques émissions de télévision
karim zaghib qui est le directeur du
centre d'excellence en électrification
des transports à hydro québec et il y a
de remporter un prix important je vous
laisse les deux discuter on va tous
discuter avec toi même donc karimi léger
pour vous appeler karim bonjour
donc c'est un homme qui est très
accessible
oui oui j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller
visiter quand même avoir un là où il ya
le centre d'excel de centres
d'excellence en électrification des
transports c'est ça et stockage
d'énergie et stockage d'énergie les
batteries oui donc karim commandes
présenter karim
les récipiendaires du prix lionel boulet
c'est le prix lionel boulet c'est l'un
des prix l'un des prix scientifiques que
rome et le gouvernement du québec chaque
année à un scientifique ou un groupe de
scientifiques quand même il est
spécialisé aussi dans les batteries et
les batteries lithium et qui dit
batteries lithium il faut se rappeler
que cette année le prix nobel de chimie
a été remis à deux chercheurs un
japonais un américain qui sont
spécialisés dans le domaine et dont l'un
d'eux est un 2 il a travaillé avec louis
pasquin des cieux mais bon oui c'est ça
parce que karim a fait un passage au
japon
si je comprends dire exactement passé à
côté il faut ya beaucoup de choses à
dire à propos de m
on va vous laisser parler monsieur karim
merci de l'invitation je suis oui je
remercie beaucoup le québec et le
gouvernement du québec pour le prix
lionel boulet et lionel boulet si le
fondateur de la place le centre de
recherche au québec et cie est un
honneur aussi travailler ici aussi c'est
moi je suis toujours ici devant les
caméras mais j'ai une équipe qui
travaille que moi les gens qui
travaillent dans l'ombre donc d'une
équipe à shawinigan kipawa rennes est
une équipe en france et nous
développement des batteries lithium ion
battery tout solide il ya peu de gens
qui savent que hydro québec aujourd'hui
c'est la seule compagnie au monde en
particulier mais gino qui est un centre
de recherche et les batteries la
recherche du développement de batteries
ça commençait dans cette place depuis
1967 et aujourd'hui j'ai dit toujours
peut-être avec une fierté aujourd'hui a
pas un téléphone portable ou un
ordinateur ou une voiture électrique ou
moins à l'intérieur d'une batterie un
élément qui est meurtri par hydro québec
je peux vous faire de faire mais je
pense que tu es cela vous a battu au fil
d'arrivée 1 ça fait cinq ans que ça vous
y travaillez donc je fais des blagues
évidemment est ce que quand vous parlez
du des applications qu'on retrouve comme
ça sur le marché partout c'est que
probablement insoupçonnées on ne sait
pas comme consommateur que ça vient que
ça a été fait chez vous et tous paient
que vous y avez bien dans la pâte
si on voit tout à l'heure il parlait de
prix django 10 nov
mais peu connu le brevet de base qui a
été breveté
moi j'étais jeune mais hydro québec il
le cnrs qui montre la conception d'une
batterie lithium-ion et la conception de
la batterie tout solide ça a été breveté
par hebdos québec qui par le service
monsieur john goodenough qui on
travaille depuis 25 ans ces récepteurs
de duperie prix nobel en chimie
c'est que le rôle d'hydro-québec nous
notre rôle c'est de faire la recherche
et développement et on s'associe avec le
manufacturier
si vous prenez l'exemple de tesla oui
l'exemple de tesla c'est un bon exemple
mais la batterie de tests classe a été
développé par panasonic par les japonais
et la compagnie qui a développé qui a
commercialisé la première batterie
lithium-ion
si sony donc juste la conception que 10
fois si mal connu oui tesla elle est
l'amie un moteur électrique avec des
batteries de panasonic avec un habitant
mais dix fois on oublie que le crédit et
il appartient à des compagnies
japonaises sont faits la
commercialisation et le brevet de base
de lithium ion
comme je dis ça a été breveté en 79 par
hydro-québec le service et monsieur john
goodenough si le premier quart a mené la
la la la cathode de quatre votes donc
hydro québec nous un autre qu'on appelle
ça le core business si plus la r et d y
développer le matériau recherché
aujourd'hui on est en cela un
gouvernement business il ya un
abaissement québec il ya toute une
stratégie pour développer une filiale
filiale d'hydro-québec avec une
stratégie de nos ressources naturelles
un écosystème québécois quand même il
faut pas qu'on oublie on a des bons
universités québécoises
on peut les comparer terre la baston
naucelle silicon valley et je pense que
nous pouvons mettre le québec sur une
belle carte pour au futur pour des
usines et on est capable de concurrence
y est
d'autres comme tesla autres à travers le
monde monsieur karim qu'est ce que votre
batterie va changer parce que je crois
comprendre qu'elle est beaucoup plus
petit et qu'elle nécessitera peut-être
moins d'utilisation des métaux précieux
oui j'avais juste pour corriger toutes
les batteries lithium-ion dont battery
niant ou la batterie tout solide il n'y
a pas des métaux rares il n'y a pas des
matériaux précieux dans une batterie
aujourd'hui on appelait lithium-ion il
ya une anode et cathode électrique
dans l'aude on utilise du cube collector
du graphite est dû un peu de silicium
dans la cathode on utilise du cobalt du
nickel et du manganèse et le collector
c'est de l'aluminium si on fait la somme
algébrique de tous ces matériaux toutes
ces ressources naturelles il existe au
québec
et si on développe la filière des
ressources naturelles au québec c'est
que il faut faire la première la
deuxième transformation qui merde
pourquoi parce qu'on à 100% notre
énergie elle est propre et coûte moins
cher et aussi on peut développer un
écosystème avec un fabricant de
batteries qu'il ya une stratégie
géographique est proche donc si ça les
matériaux et ont pensé au québec aussi
si on est dans un l'endroit
politiquement stable et on a accès de
toutes les marchés le marché de l'europe
le marché n'a milles du nord des etats
unis le mexique le marché de l'amérique
du sud est aussi là le marché de
l'asie-pacifique et ça ça nous donne
accès à peu près à 2 milliards de
clients et de plus on est proche aussi
des marchés on en périodes on a forgé un
chrysler et dodge
donc là on a un écosystème qui est
impressionnant au québec et on peut
faire transformer nos ressources
naturelles
ici au québec vous avez ma question je
reviens d'une syndication très pratico
pratique les gens soupçonnent parfois
les batteries si toutes ces histoires de
batteries qui explose c'est dû à quoi ou
est ce que c'est juste une légende
urbaine où on habitait cela qui a
explosé ou une parité cela une voiture
récemment hissé à montréal pour l'été
dernier il y avait une voiture je pense
une hyundai qui a explosé on sait pas
pourquoi mais alors est ce que est ce
qu'il ya des choses qui sont faites pour
réduire ces risques là aujourd'hui on a
deux types de lithium ion
on n'appelle ni commis à 1 m cn s'est
assaini qu'elles combattent aluminium
qui sont l'oxygène et on a des batteries
lithium-ion fer phosphate
aujourd'hui la majorité des voitures
électriques utilisent du nickel combourg
aluminium ou du nickel manganèse cobol
avec l'oci est ce qu'aujourd'hui toutes
les batteries lithium-ion l'électrolyte
c'est un électrique inflammable c'est
comme les sens en revanche on explique
c'est un triangle de feu on à l'oxygène
on a les sens et on al ahly m la limite
c'est quoi c'est le court-circuit au
l'accident les sens et l'électrolyte
inflammable et l'oxygène vient de la
cathode et oui oui à un problème au
niveau de la sécurité
tout le monde travaille sur la spree
mais en revanche il faut pas avoir peur
lorsqu'on conduit une voiture électrique
aujourd'hui parce qu'on utilise qu'on
appelle ça des batteries management
system excusez ma môme au monoxyde de
gestion de batterie gestion assez
protégé et on fait aussi sûr qu'il ya
liquide de refroidissement en de
maintenir toujours la température et on
met la batterie dans une cage vraiment
pratiquement blindés donc les risques et
peut aimer en revanche nous nous dit bhl
on a déjà développé des batteries
sécuritaire avec le carrosse fait le fer
phosphate donc ya pas de risque mais en
revanche densité d'énergie au niveau
lithium-ion et à 25% moins nous on veut
changer la trilogie au complet ça veut
dire que dalle et de la batterie
lithium-ion à une batterie tout solide
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
naude la cathode électrolytes elle est
solide
tout est ok avoir plus de problèmes de
freins et en revanche on va augmenter la
densité d'énergie augmenter la densité
d'énergie c'est quoi aujourd'hui
là dans cette énergie aller de 250 watts
heure par kilogramme
on veut aller vers 500 watts par
kilogramme ça veut dire quoi - qu'il a
dansé d'énergie ça veut dire on va
augmenter l'autonomie et si on augmente
l'autonomie ont valu à peu près de 400 à
800 km une fois qu'on arrive à 800
kilomètres donc on n'aura pas à tout en
charger la batterie salariale problème
du condo niant des condos le problème
des installations dans un appartement
dont convenait pas et aussi le prix ce
que nous
aujourd'hui le prix d'une batterie
lithium-ion au niveau kilowattheure on
en parle un prix de 200 à 220 les
curateurs nous on veut réduire le prix
de cette batterie parce que cette
batterie
elles demandent pas beaucoup d'énergie
demande pas beaucoup d'étapes de
fabrication ont valu vers 100 dollars le
kilo à terre et à 100 $ kilowattheures
par pac
on n'aura pas besoin de subventions et
le prix de la voiture électrique il se
rapproche de la voiture à essence
est-ce que vous avez un véhicule
électrique bonne question
ab3 a pris 25 ont la même avec les
batteries au plan là je roule toujours
avait il faut que je donne l'exemple
aujourd'hui je roule avec une voiture
mitsubishi plugin qui fait 65 65 km mana
mana ont même il ne borne on pense au
futur donc on a une bonne qu'on appelle
véhicule tout véhicule torrent on pense
aussi au haut niveau du réseau parce que
plus tard le client il devient
participatif et mon auto dans quelques
années je peux vendre l'électricité à
hydro-québec 30 ans de femmes une fille
ma patrie comme génératrice pour ma
maison
ouais écoutez blague à part vous auriez
pu être milliardaire et vous offrir en
ce moment une tesla
c'est pas le cas vous avez décidé de
travailler pour le secteur plouasne oui
c'est une question qui se pose
oui généralement si je suis juste à
l'université ou à l'extérieur
la propriété intellectuelle appartient
50% ont cherché c'est le contraire qui
aideront québec toute la propriété
intellectuelle sale arabe est un pas
hydro québec sera un bon sens et à la
patrimoine québécois et on reçoit moins
tous les chercheurs ici on reçoit 0 $
sur ces camps 550 inventions je peux
être d'une dizaine de millions jusqu'à 1
milliard
mais c'est une passion qui dit ben si tu
as choix personnel et
moi j'ai pris une direction avec mon
équipe de travailler pour les intérêts
supérieurs du québec d'hydro québec et
l'humanité comme on dit en argent avec
des quêtes ou match au nord de manille
mais est ce le fait tous tige est un
excellent salaire je dois avoir une
bonne retraite
et il le fait que j'essaierai de ramener
un grain pour brider l'humanité le
réchauffement de la planète on le sait
assez manichéen disparaître eh bien
écoutez fantastique on est bien content
vous avoir eu l'émission on vous a
adopté parce qu'on vous appelle monsieur
monsieur karim mais voilà très touché
alors merci beaucoup
alors c'était karim zaghib directeur du
centre d'excellence en électrification
des transports à hydro québec va ce
merci nous avons ramené cet invité à
merci à lui aussi de faire le travail
mais bini venue des idées pendant qu'il
parlait nous aussi de propriété
intellectuelle on la donne 100% aux
patrons à radio canada sans recevoir un
sou il ya des choses communes j'ai aussi
mes minime est venu il parle toujours de
ses batteries moi j'ai quelque chose de
très simple à leur proposer je pense que
ça peut être étudiée c'est une pomme de
terre
je pense après servir de batteries j'ai
une idée comme ça sur laquelle je
travaille depuis deux ans enfin oui
alors en cours ans d'expérience aux
primaires avec la pomme de terre
on en fait non vous êtes c'est plus
avancée mais mon père produit devait pas
être producteur de pâtes pommes de terre
c'est en face oui il avait failli c'est
fait oui mais il a fait faillite
à l'époque on peut pas vendre sa hydro
québec alors écoutez ça enfin joué à
beaucoup de faire si rien de vrai dans
ce que je raconte
peut-être seulement la moitié est ce
qu'il reste une question oui la grosse
boule
mais avant la grosse boule je sais qu'on
ne pouvait perdu 20 points vous piaffez
d'impatience
on va y aller la grosse boule puisque
vous y tenez temps à perdre 50 boules
d'henri vous en avez perdu seulement 30
à 70 sinon je pensais qu'on avait perdu
dès la 1ère cat nova eu il va changer de
compliquer pas les choses nous on avait
perdu 30 seulement sur 50 jusqu'à
maintenant
à 5 ans non sincère sur sa lancée on est
à 70 en a quatre on est à 70 très bien
alors faisons c'est qu'on n'a jamais
fait un bon avocat parce que vous êtes
confondues le troisième bull grosse
question
alors vous aussi on la fiche au début de
19 films de 2019
il y avait combien de véhicules
électriques et hybrides hybrides et
hybrides traction hybride aussi au jeu
inclure ça sur la planète
est-ce que c'est moins de 6 millions
est-ce que cb - 2 5 millions ou est ce
que c'est c'est moins de 26 millions à
gérer pour nos attendait alors la
première fois j'ai entendu de faire
parler des véhicules hybrides toyota
prius entre a et b ça c'est quelque part
entre a et b selon les sources à chacun
de nous prend à sur 10 et 1 californie
il en avait 40 millions d'habitants a de
plus qui scénarise et les japonais de
l'autre côté norvégien de l'autre on va
foncer sur le sait vous avez pour le
moins de vingt-six écoute
est-ce que je devrais la rigidité
d'accord l'origine c'est vraiment avec
le sait s'est allongée pour le bateau va
dire quelque chose aux âmes alberta qui
s'appelle le boulot ce match de bordeaux
htc ce smash ten kate nash tembo en
obtient alors cela ils ont découvert des
ossements de vous voulez nous dire quoi
on sait qu'on va regarder a affiché la
bonne réponse c'est seulement passé
la régie en reste 70 puisqu'elle n'a
participé qu'à la deux êtres à la
troisième question
howie la régie il serait ce que
seulement en fin d'émission à propos de
batterie je ne sais pas ça m'est revenue
à l'idée je me suis rappelé qu' est-ce
que vous savez que car il nous arrive
dans son équipe il sur l'histoire des
batteries stockage d'électricité ce
n'est pas juste des batteries de voiture
c'est aussi ils vont dans des
communautés où ils peuvent mettre des
containers comme une grosse batterie qui
peut fournir l'électricité avant par
exemple celle et en or chez je connais
pas c'est un droit a touché deux
communautés amérindiennes ils auront
fourni avec les listes avec le solaire
ils peuvent récupérer d'électricité dans
des batteries piles les acteurs dont
nous vraiment dans leurs recherches il
ya une partie transport et une partie
stockage dynamique et très c'est la
décentralisation des infrastructures
c'est l'avenir
j'ai aimé le fait que ça qu'on peut
remettre l'électricité à hydro québec -
là on peut faire du beurre électriques
quelque chose que vous
on peut nous nous autres on peut aussi
produire à acheter allait acheter le nom
le nom tout de suite hubert lecteurs je
vous donne la libéralisation de
lectrices inondées et est déjà fait deux
côtés du maire hubert isation
d'électricité 166 jeu on va vous laisser
sur la dernière vidéo c'est pour en
savoir plus depuis samedi on vous avait
parlé de nodo qui explosait ça vous
allez voir on a préparé cette vidéo sur
les documents qui accompagne cette
émission jean jules pas à temps canada
sur notre page web
on montre ça il ya six reportages en
tout je pense que le deuxième c'est
concernant ce véhicule automobile qui a
exposé exposé cet exposé certainement
qu'il explose c'est la deuxième voilà
une des passions l enquête sur
l'explosion d'une voiture électrique à
montréal ou dans un garage d'une
résidence
et heureusement qu'ils avaient peu
heureusement qu'il y avait personne
sinon d'autres reportages de canada doit
résolument pour en mouvoir des autos les
autobus urbain à montréal il ya un
autobus au projet pilote l' electrical
récemment qu'une sortie puis ils adorent
outre d'autres nouvelles notamment la
chine qui s'impliquent qui pourrait
déjouer les projets de plusieurs et en
attendant les avions électriques communs
l'iran le plus écologique ça ya quelques
semaines à peine wattignies sion ont pas
les avions électriques
s'en viennent mais en attendant il va
falloir dépolluer le ciel il ya des gros
problèmes si j'allais à ce sujet là
voilà pour ceux qui veulent lire et
quand il ya aussi l'article café maryse
sur karim zaghib quand il a eu son prix
aussi oui tout à fait parce que passer
l'image de presse qui est allé sur place
mais on peut trouver beaucoup
d'informations simplement on t'a pas son
nom car on vole on va rajouter vous avez
tout ce qu'il faut gouvernement du
québec
tout ce qu'il a reçu comme prix c'est
vraiment la route et récemment la
stratégie du gouvernement sur les
lithium sur l'industrie du lithium au
québec aussi
c'est vraiment serré sans savoir qu'il
ya deux ou trois semaines donc
donc il ya des choses a ajouté zhu et va
jouer exactement écoutez c'est tout pour
cette semaine la semaine prochaine on va
parler de la santé on va parler d'un
problème de santé important à la fura
pas de surprise la sna français alors à
la semaine prochaine merci
[Musique]